[Music]
okay we just got done seeing one was
about Laurel and Hardy which is about
Stanley stan and Ollie yeah and this
movie just kind of came out of nowhere
on the AMC app I mean there wasn't any
didn't see any previews and didn't even
say coming soon
just boom yeah it seems like it just
kind of popped up and the poster knows I
guess he didn't buy any they didn't buy
any promotional stuff yeah we didn't see
any trailers or it or anything
who was the who started in st john c
reilly was yang Oliver Hardy and Steve
Coogan I love Steve Coogan was playing
Stan Laurel
yeah and Riley was the same guy that was
in Watson right yeah yeah okay was it
Holmes and Watson he was in the sisters
brothers yes and he was in a fat suit to
make him look a bit fatter yes this is a
perfectly good movie there's nothing
wrong with it the the script I thought
was pretty tight sets looked really cool
there were a lot of Art Deco sets acting
was good and I think it was a very good
portrayal of of what those guys were
like and what their material was like
you know just a perfectly okay movie
yeah I actually really liked it because
what it is it doesn't focus on Laurel
and Hardy when they were like super
famous like thirties
you know they even said at the beginning
like the peak of their popularity was
about 1937 right this actually takes
place 16 years later yeah careers are
kind of very very much older yeah and
this was like this movie producer guy or
somebody had like set up this tour and
this is actually they showed actual
photographs at the end like during the
credits of the actual people who've been
doing it so this was like so they're
like touring England yeah you know doing
their their vaudevillian shtick yeah and
their days they're doing vaudeville
stuff that's very out of date but
surprisingly
they were able to pull it out and
actually started to pack theaters it's
in kind of like a comeback tour yeah and
they're trying to raise the money and
trying to trying to bring their careers
back up to a point to where a studio
will make a movie yeah they want to make
another one so they're doing like this
live show and it's kind of yeah it's
it's actually it's it's really good like
I thought it was like a really you know
what I thought about this it's really
sweet yeah it's a buddy picture yeah it
was like it just kind of like um it's a
it's a lot it's it's about friendship
and it's about loyalty into their ship
with each other and you know and it was
actually really really also about
forgiving yeah you know which is kind of
like actually you know in my experience
you know dude bros and dudes forgive
each other and really they get into that
a lot yeah and I really like that aspect
also I should say I know that Shirley
Henderson played Oliver Hardy's wife and
I've seen lots of other movies yes that
is her real voice I've seen her another
baby she has a very very squeaky voice
yeah yes so she plays Oliver Hardy's
wife now the woman that played Stan
laurels wife the Russian girl knocked it
out of the park those two yeah they
almost stole the movie and like when the
two of them were sniping at each other
and everything like that just these
little barbs they had each other than
like the girl that was playing the
Russian girls yes
Stan's Stan's wife was that kind of a
no-nonsense Russian ballbreaker girl who
is the answer yeah she's a dancer dancer
and an actress and she's not he's quite
cool like when the two of them like came
into the movie like later on it's like
like I said they almost stole the movie
is because they're like interactions
we're so funny
yeah and you know their interactions
were like way funnier than Laurel and
Hardy's actually we had to do the review
outside the car because once again we
were invaded by old people that this
movie was an old people Maggie
people magnet and boy they were talking
beginning and after that you want to
leave the theater they loved it yeah
yeah old people love this move but they
were hanging out in the hallway like you
know they were all yeah I think they
were in their 80s yeah but no good movie
I could recommend it I mean it's not an
action movie you know time out sci-fi
this is a buddy flick yeah and it's like
it's a comedy drama yeah like a lot of
the comedy is very sit Steve Coogan yeah
it's you know it's like very and low-key
and comedy doesn't come from Laurel and
Hardy acts their material is just not
funny by today's yeah they were laughing
they were laughing about it the audience
the old people in the audience were
laughing over the Laurel harder material
reiated me and her just looking like
people and you know characters in the
movie funny was just like the
relationship between the two guys in the
[ __ ] that they did yeah that was like
that's the part of the movie and I think
that was kind of like the whole that's
the purpose of the purpose of the movie
was just showing their friendship and
their declining years and yeah their
friendship was a lot more funny than
their material yes yeah they were doing
yeah all right so we'll just leave it
that it's good
you
okay we just got done seeing the kid who
would be king which is it's a
continuation of the King Arthur legend
if you ever saw that original old
Excalibur movie from the 70s that has 82
82 it was directed by the guy who did
sawed off excellently this one kind of
fits right along in there with the same
yeah you'd even had some callbacks to
the yes the originally yeah it didn't
quite capture that same kind of dark
gravitas that Excalibur did but the
intended audience is very different in
this one you can tell it was an intended
for a younger audience you know tweens
may be you know yeah they take they took
the Arthurian legend and it kind of
continued it and they're kinda I would
say give it a the Harry Potter treatment
yeah it was a similar temporary yeah it
was very much a similar tongue that very
first hand
Harry Potter and the way they kind of
wrap up the story they let you know that
this is kind of like an origin story and
it's gonna continue and it may not
involve swords or you know things like
that or you know an armor when I first
saw the the trailer I just did not want
to see this but watching the movie it
was competently done and it was well
written it it didn't make a lot of the
mistakes that a lot of kids moving kids
movies make they kind of stuck true to
the Arthurian legends of the past and
then they also kind of
held true to the to the hero's journey
format where things didn't come easily
they actually had to kind of suffer for
him that they didn't pull together as a
team at first they actually had to train
and learn how to fight you know which I
appreciated that part of the movie yeah
that it didn't come easy in that you
actually went and really kind of what
that does is that condom makes the
audience suspect that the stakes are
maybe high that maybe they won't all
make yeah that type of deal so it adds
tension other than that you know our man
thought the movie was good for its
intended audience I don't know if it'll
succeed in rebooting a series of or art
theory and Legends champions yeah you
know it's difficult to say how the
market will react to it but yeah I feel
like it would probably do pretty well I
mean the Harry Potter movies you know
it's a similar kind of ain't like I said
I think the problem with the trailer was
that I think made it look very silly
well they've retreated as being yeah
like that MC knee and stuff like that
which them
I guess the premise could be silly to
know it's like a bunch of little kids
yeah it is a 12 year old kennedy drum
yeah the trailers but it actually it had
like little funny moments but it did
itself very seriously yeah it was a
serious story that was danger the scary
parts you know what I mean it it wasn't
like this whack you know like hijinks
rush it you know what
it was actually like a Harry Potter type
movie where you throw like a bunch
little kids they had to pull the yard
you know they got beat up and all yeah I
think I think the original I think the
trailer should have kind of actually
kind of focused more on their little bit
of the darker aspects of the movie
really and I think it would have
attracted more of my attention but like
I said you know I mean it the intended
audience is pretty young yeah even
though we were sitting in the theater
full of old people watching it yeah and
they were talking one no but I think the
audience because a couple things that
stood out of the movie is that it opened
up with an animated scene that was
excellent yeah credits that was really
nicely I could have watched the whole
movie like that where they're retelling
the Arthurian legend in case you don't
know because a lot of the kids wouldn't
know nothing that stands out is that all
the acting was good yeah everything
liked like the the four main casting is
good are really good like they're all
like kind of different personality types
but you were totally bought yeah
eventually like after awhile they
actually kind of pulled the you as a
team human one of that little Indian
game yeah one of them that really stood
out to me was the the actor that played
Lance which is kind of like a
reincarnation of Lancelot yeah this kids
kind of a spitting image of a young
Billy Idol he's a Draco Malfoy type yeah
and he immediately struck me as star
material I wouldn't be surprised at all
if that kid continues on he's got a
great face yeah he would really make a
really good James Bond in about 15 years
yeah if you imagine that scene that kid
is James Bond but he's good he's good
because like he started out like he
started I was kind of a villain because
he's like you know the media bully and
everything like that but but he kind of
it can be a good guy too so yeah yeah I
think yeah he was really gonna they were
all good all the kids were all the kids
were good but for me that kid stuck out
I think that if long as he does and long
as he follows the correct career path
you'll see that guy in more movies yeah
yeah he's probably 16 17 yeah he might
be older than he looks playing which
means which means in 10 years he could
play a young bot
yeah yeah I was thinking man adieu to
make a good change Bob yeah after Daniel
Craig is gone you know but actually I
really like I said you know if you like
Harry Potter I can't imagine why you
wouldn't like this because similar
fantasy with like you know kids that age
like 12 and up yeah you know there's
some darker [ __ ] it like with the stuff
they do with Morgana like all of her
nights and stuff like that are really
cool again yeah so you know I can't see
if the movie succeeds I can't see why
they wouldn't make more of these yeah
and just watching the movie I think it
has a good chance of succeeding but they
never can't tell man the morning they
never know but I think it's seems like
something that would probably be I mean
Arthurian legends you kind of can't go
wrong with that it was done right so all
right yeah good movie I guess yeah
you
okay just got done seeing miss Paula and
miss Paula was a action-adventure flick
about a mexican-american girl that gets
abducted by narco terrorists it's kind
like an elite gang and narco terrorists
and the DEA thinks she's working with
them so she kind of gets she can't she
tries to escape but she gets caught in
between the DEA and a narco terrorist
group and it gets worse from there
it was a bad [ __ ] so [ __ ] cool flick
I did the the trailer for this is
absolutely abominable terrible didn't
represent this movie at all this movie
was uh quite cool it was kind of like a
mixture of girl to dragon tattoo James
Bond and it's happened it's happening in
Tijuana good for locations in Tijuana
and sometimes too but it's based on a
evidently a long-running novella prior
to this although I'm not sure what the
name of it was good acting good
soundtrack good action very good writing
the story was solid and the the movie
ends up being a an origin story for this
character so I'm pretty sure they're
gonna make other ones yeah I kind of
hope they do because I really really
liked her character and the cool thing
about this movie like I said it's like
the trailer wasn't awful it just didn't
really stop there's a lot different than
the trailer could kind of lead you to
believe the movies a lot deeper a lot
heavier a lot better
and there's a lot of like surprises yes
like the way the trailer goes it's like
you pretty much think you know how the
story is gonna go but that's not how it
no and but I like that it was like this
really labyrinthine like complex comes
due process in triple cross yeah it's
like all this crazy [ __ ] going on so you
didn't really know what to expect him
that's yeah I mean it was just and that
to other than like the acting being
excellent this yeah tog Rafi foodists
like the way it was shot was really kind
of like the morality is very gray in it
too it's kind of like good and bad the
other only only the the star miss Bala
only her morality I would say is
straight because all she was trying to
do was save her it was save her friend
what disappeared after a rough shootout
and she was like little work which
wasn't she got sucked into this horrible
yeah she'd do a lot of bad stuff to get
through it yeah I'm like it really like
no one is a good guy but she just had to
kind of like Roy everybody off each
other and [ __ ] like yeah to get what she
wanted and so yeah it's this moment was
like I I wasn't you know I I was like
that might be pretty good in my pret I
don't know I can really tell my
best-known a mediocre yes it's like he
was like the trailer looks so bad as I
don't want to see this but then like all
the way out he's like wow that was me
and luckily we saw it in the Dolby
theater yeah everything the fire breaks
boom no secret was promised yeah I like
to have a theaters actually I liked how
they portrayed the the narco terrorist
group really good guns showed them
training and working out and trying to
get better at their trade they all had
kind of you know realistic equipment
they could they could do a lot of stuff
like impersonate police it was good yeah
yeah it had a lot of money they had good
taste in things they could just take
over houses they had the best of
everything
they would just capture women when they
wanted him it was a trip yeah it was
trip but yeah I really really do
recommend this
really really good yeah there's good
[Music]